aughh functions it's good to know what
the parent function looks like the basic
graph of a log function and that's what
I've drawn here for us you can see the
log graph it looks like this it's the
inverse of the exponential growth graph
okay and you can see these are
reflections over the line y equals x but
when you look at the log graph you can
see that it's always greater than zero
you can see it never touches the y axis
is always to the right here and so the
domain for this function right here
would be that X has to be greater than
zero or if you're using the interval
notation you can say from zero to
infinity now you might get it a little
bit more you know challenge or a
complicated one such as this but all you
would do is you would take this quantity
right here which is called the argument
of the log and you just make that
greater than zero and solve for X so
here you can see if we add 5 to both
sides we get 2x is greater than 5 divide
both sides by 2 and you can see that X
is greater than 5 halves so that would
be your domain or if you want to write
it in interval notation it's 5 halves to
infinity so that's all you need to do to
find the domain for logs just go ahead
and set that argument greater than 0 and
solve for X and that's going to be your
domain so I hope that helped you
understand how to work with the domains
of logs better subscribe to the channel
check out some more math videos on
Mario's math tutor and YouTube channel
and I look forward to seeing the future
videos I'll talk to you soon